[Music]
we're going back to Westerose although
the second season of House of the Dragon
has been filmed completely post-
production is still in full swing
however most of the plot of season 2 is
being kept close to the vest so far
nevertheless there was always some
initial information about the cast and
the story in this original we are
presenting you a first overview of what
to expect in the second season and what
else you can look forward to in the Game
of Thrones
Universe the final season of Game OF
Thrones left the majority of fans
disappointed therefore the prequel House
of the Dragon should make everything
better the show is based on Georgia RR
Martin's book Blood and fire and tells
the story of a war within house
targarian this war takes place nearly
200 years before the events of Game of
Thrones and we'll go down in the history
books as the dance of the Dragons the
war starts after the death of King
viseris and is fought by two parties on
one side the family of princess reira
and her Uncle Demon on the other side
Alison the wife of the deceased King
with her sons Ean and Egon the two sides
are called the blacks and the greens
after the colors of their
houses we can currently assume that
season 2 will be entirely dedicated to
the bloody Civil War the first trailer
already promises plenty of action and a
dramatic clash between the two sides
screenwriter Sarah Hess revealed in an
interview with variety that there will
be a special storyline in the second
season which is opposed to deal with a
cruel Revenge plot by rira and Demon she
mentioned two keywords that should
already be familiar to Die Hard book
fans blood and
cheese series Creator Ryan condo has
already confirmed that we will be seeing
most of the first season's characters
again including of course Emma Darcy as
rira targarian Matt Smith as demon
targarien Olivia Cook as Allison high
tower and Reese ey fans as her father
sir AO hi Tower additionally we can also
look forward to Tom Glen Cy as Egon II
you and Mitchell is Iman and fiia saan
as Helen at targarian sorely missed by
fans but confirmed for season two how
Stark is finally playing a larger role
more specifically it's about the ruler
of the north KGAN Stark who according to
initial rumors be played by the last
Kingdom star Tom Taylor a return of the
young versions of rira and Allison in
the form of Millie Alcock and Emily kery
is not planned as the plot is to be
entirely without
flashbacks House of the Dragon is one of
the few Productions that was not
affected by the actors and writer strike
the scripts had already been completed
before the strike began and the actor's
contracts ran through England trade
unions season 2 was shot in September
2023 and is scheduled to premere on HBO
in summer
2024 unlike the mother Series Game of
Thrones the story of the prequel was
already set before the start of the
first season therefore we can presumably
expect a well-rounded and self-contained
story according to the current status
two more seasons are to follow season 2
the current season will include Eight
Episodes and therefore be slightly
shorter than season 1 however according
to the producers the advantage of having
fewer episodes is that there is still
enough story left to fill the other
seasons for example a very important
battle which was originally planned for
season 2 will now only take place in
season
3 House of the Dragon is by no means the
end of the story after all there are
already quite a few titles circulating
the net that also have enough potential
for a realization some of them have
already been
confirmed Dance of the Dragons is to be
followed by another prequel series
entitled KN of the Seven Kingdoms which
has already been commissioned by HBO of
the Seven Kingdoms is also set before
Game of Thrones and tells the story of
The Young and naive hedge Knight Duncan
who travels through the lands and
experiences adventures with his Squire
egg anyone who is already familiar with
the Game of Thrones universe will know
that the Squire egg is Egon V targarian
work on the scripts has already started
according to producer Franchesca ory the
series will be significantly smaller
than its
predecessors additionally a sequel that
is entitled snow will also be released
the series will take place after the
events of season 8 of Game of Thrones it
will feature new stories around Jon Snow
who once again be played by kit
Harrington we can also look forward to a
series about Egon the Conqueror the show
is about how he became king of Westeros
and had the Iron Throne built however
the project is currently still at a very
early stage of development meaning
nothing is really known yet about the
cast or exact plot details in addition
to the already confirmed spin-offs many
other projects have been mentioned but
according to George RR Martin not all of
them can be realized it's more about
collecting ideas and then to find out
which of these ideas have the greatest
potential that was the latest
information on the new season of House
of the dragon and the future of the Game
of Thrones Universe in general how do
you like the direction the franchise is
heading let us know in the comments and
like the video If you enjoyed our
[Music]
preview